I knew him when he was Joel Katz the
next award voted by the Academy Board is
a very special one it's for a gentleman
named Charles Boren who has never put on
makeup changed a light bulb or Bennett
been to a studio except is a very
welcome visitor to the industry he
served so well his work has been
indispensable to present the award
another indispensable man the vice
president of the afl-cio and president
of the international alliance of
theatrical and stage employees mr.
Richard Walsh
mr. porn is a very special man in our
industry he helped the labor people
negotiate the 5-day week in this
industry he helped us negotiate the
Health and Welfare Fund and he helped us
negotiate our fine pension plan
inscribed on this Austin is a child as
born leader for 38 years the industry's
enlightened labor relations an architect
of the policy of non-discrimination with
the respect and affection of all who
work in filaments Charlie it affords me
greatest amount of pleasure on behalf of
all the filling workers to present to
you this Oscar
and profoundly grateful to the Board of
Governors of the Academy this cherished
award is a distinction which will
forever remain indelibly in my memory I
accept it with a deep humility to have
worked for and with the people of our
industry has been a rare privilege it
has been an enjoyable and rewarding
experience to all my colleagues many
many colleagues who have made this
possible my eternal thanks